[Music]
my name is jordan chan
and my family and i were recently
victims
of racial aggression on the 4th of july
my dad is full chinese
and my mom is full filipino it's very
important that
people expose racists and white
supremacists
and i also just wanted people to know
that this is something that is
really really close to home it could
literally be anyone in anywhere
i'm an american citizen i was born in
wisconsin
but my parents were doing long distance
when i was a kid so my dad has always
lived in the philippines
and it was too hard for them we ended up
moving to the philippines
when i was around five years old i would
say i did all of my
elementary school my preschool half of
high school
and then i moved to california around
seven years ago for my junior year of
high school
i've always felt like i'm too asian for
my american friends
and i'm too american for my asian
friends
i've never personally experienced
anything like to the point where i would
consider
it bullying but i know my family has
mostly like my dad and my brother who
have told me like
their experiences in school and work
where they've experienced racism
in america
[Music]
maitita's birthday is on the 4th of july
so we planned this year
to drive to monterey to celebrate and so
we were at the
restaurant lucille's at bernardus lodge
and spa which is
a really nice fine dining restaurant we
were celebrating her birthday dinner and
we were
singing happy birthday to her and then
michael lofthouse who
you can see in the video he's sitting on
the table right behind my
quito while we were singing happy
birthday he starts
saying like you asians go back to
whatever
asian country you came from my family
and i then exchanged confused looks
it was so unwarranted and like
completely unprovoked so we were kind of
just like
is he talking to us it was very obvious
that alcohol played a factor into his
bluntness and so my uncle and i turn
around to him and we're like
what's your problem and then he just
goes on this rant like you guys don't
belong here
asians and that's when i started
recording him say one more time
you need to leave asian pieces oh my god
when all of that was going down
everybody was staring obviously this was
like
a very loud altercation in a very fancy
place
and so everyone was kind of just staring
and in shock you know when that happens
nobody really knows how to react because
it's not normal you know but then
once jennica who's the server who got
involved and was like defending
my family other people started joining
in too you are not allowed here i
already i
already put my i'll talk to your guests
like that get out
yeah you you're a racist after when
michael was being escorted off the
premises
he actually tried approaching our table
but then jennica the server and
two other customers got involved and
they were like serving as a barrier
between us and him
it's something like a lot of people are
desensitized to but when it's
happening to you in the moment and like
you are personally being targeted i
don't know how to explain it's
completely different
as soon as he he was like completely
gone
i just started sobbing uncontrollably
at the dinner table my uncle while i was
crying he was like saying you have to
forgive and forget because that's the
christian thing to do
and that made me really angry because
you know that whole mantra of forgiving
and forgetting in
instances of any social injustice just
perpetuates it
it teaches them that they can get away
with it we have to show people that
racism
on any level is an intolerable offense
they were like this is normal like we've
experienced
racism maybe not on that scale but it's
definitely happened before and it'll it
probably will happen again but
that made me cry even harder because i
was like
it shouldn't be that way and this isn't
something that should be
glossed over or tolerated this is
completely unacceptable that people have
to
even live in fear of that when i first
posted it
which was on the fifth the day after it
happened it was mostly a lot of love and
support i received you know because at
first it was just like people who
followed me like my friends and family
and co-workers etc but
then when it blew up like it went viral
that's when i started receiving a lot of
hate i actually had to turn disable my
notifications for instagram
and i just went private recently people
will say
a lot of racist remarks or they'll
kind of try to do whatever they can to
manipulate my words or
like kind of flip the situation on its
head and make it seem like i was
aggravating him or my family
in some way deserved his racist remarks
so when i first heard the apology i
did not believe it was genuine because
when the video went viral and it reached
michael he actually commented on my on
my original
post of the video of him and he said you
can eat
he was sober because that happened after
the
video was posted
so a few of my friends have recently
notified me that
jennica the server who's seen in the
video
defending my family and i has actually
received nearly a hundred thousand
dollars
because a bunch of people like around
the world just started gofundme pages
for her
to tip her what jennika did was really
really wonderful
and she deserves praise for that she was
being a really good ally but
the fact that people are calling her
a hero and that's a word i've been
seeing a lot
everywhere in the media i think that's
really really problematic
and toxic because why should it be seen
as something that's heroic
to stand up for what's right like
literally
everybody should do that if if they're
placed in that instance
i just think it speaks to a bigger
problem and that's something that's
really
hard to talk about because obviously
this dialogue is super super important
because it feeds into
the white savior complex it's such a
difficult
discussion to have with people online
because people are
quick again to be defensive and be like
oh why are you attacking white people
when they're trying to be your allies
but there's a huge difference between
being an
ally and a savior so i would say one
important thing is
if you see it happening and it doesn't
have to be happening to you you have to
call it out
you have to make sure that those people
know that that's not okay
and another thing is that people have to
be
open to being wrong it's really
important to
just reflect and sit down take a beat
for a minute and be like
okay why does this person think
that what i'm saying or doing is racist
and how can i
be better we all have to be open to
making mistakes and being corrected
nobody's born woke like we all have to
learn and unlearn
[Music]